Wilson: Hi. I'm Brett,
if you don't know me.
Okay, so I'm gonna be
talking about...
Not working. Okay.
Okay. I'm gonna be talking
about the layers of our program.
Chrome is like an onion
or a parfait,
where there's many layers
that go deeper and deeper.
[laughs]
Onion parfait.
So first I'm gonna show you
how to get to the information
that I'm gonna tell you
so you can look it up later when
you aren't watching the talk.
So this is the Chromium
developer site
on dev.chromium.org.
And what you do is you first
click on For Developers,
'cause you're a developer.
And...the things
I'm gonna be discussing
are under the engineering
design docs here at the bottom.
So if you go to the engineering
design docs...
these first two things are
probably the most important.
So there's the Multi-process
Architecture
which Darin talked about,
and here it's got an overview
of everything.
If you're confused
about what Darin said,
this is a good place to start.
Um...the other thing
to look at is...
how Chromium displays
web pages,
which is what I'm gonna
be talking about today.
So it's got a discussion
of everything.
You have diagrams
and stuff like that.
So this is one of the diagrams
from that page
that I'm gonna be discussing
a lot.
So Dimitri just talked
about WebKit,
which is at the bottom.
That's kind of our low level
library that we use
for rendering web pages.
As he said,
that lives on webkit.org,
and if we change it,
you have to change it on WebKit,
and then we pull it
to our tree.
So historically we also
had a WebKit port,
and the WebKit port
provides integration
with the graphics layer
like Skia, system fonts,
the network.
And we've got our own
implementation
of all those things--
that's called our port.
And we've recently moved
our WebKit port
into the WebKit tree.
So that means anytime
you need to change something
with fonts or graphics,
you're gonna have to also
make it a patch to WebKit,
even though it only really
affects us right now.
So these two things,
both of them on WebKit,
and they cannot depend
on any other parts of Chrome.
Because they live
in WebKit's tree,
they should be able
to compile by themselves.
[clears throat]
So the next layer is
the WebKit glue
which we have in
our WebKit directory/glue.
And that kinda provides
a wrapper around WebKit
that we use to access it.
And so it does several things.
It provides, uh...
type independence.
So WebKit uses
its own string types,
its own URL types.
It has lots of dependencies
all over the place.
And we don't wanna have Chrome
inherit all that stuff,
'cause we're gonna be confused
with, you know,
ten different string types
and, uh, you know,
two URL classes.
So the WebKit glue's job
is to translate types
between, for example,
a GURL and a KURL...
Um...or a WebCore string
to a standard string.
And so it kind of provides
all the, uh...
an implementation
of all the interfaces
that WebKit uses.
So there might be a frame loader
client callback thing.
It will implement its own,
convert it to Google types,
and then it will have
its own callback interface
that you'll have to implement.
So there's kind of a hop
as you go across this boundary.
And so if you do need
to get something...
if you're in our WebKit port
and you need to
get something from the browser,
like the browser process
or something higher level,
you actually have to go through
this delegate interface.
That hops through
to the WebKit glue,
and then that's implemented
at a higher level.
So the WebKit glue
shouldn't depend on
any other parts of Chrome.
It's basically
our embedding layer,
so you should be able
to write a new browser
using our WebKit glue,
totally different in every way.
And we have such a browser
called TestShell
which is a separate browser
that just uses our WebKit glue,
has its own simple front end,
and that's it.
So TestShell can't depend on
any other parts of Chrome
other than base.
So, um, here's our directory.
So base here at the top
is kind of used by everything
except the WebCore code,
which obviously isn't ours.
So WebKit glue depends on this.
We've got our network library
that depends on this.
You know, we've got our sandbox
But basically nothing else here
except Chrome
depends on anything but base.
So for example,
Net doesn't depend on
you know, Media or ICP
or Gears or Chrome.
And then Chrome kind of brings
all these things together
into the final product.
So hopefully, this makes it
easy for projects
to pick up
our different components
from these top level
directories.
They just have to take base
and the sandbox or whatever.
So um...
Okay, so WebKit glue depends
on base, and that's it.
So you can write
a new browser, um...
that's single process.
Or you can use our multi-process
embedding layer,
which is,
as Darin talked about,
it's got the RenderProcess
and, uh--
okay, let me talk about that.
[laughs]
So the RenderProcess
is kind of implemented
in this render project
which is in Chrome/renderer.
So these are things like
RenderView and RenderWidget.
They're called Render.
Everything starts with Render.
And that talks to the
corresponding interfaces
on the browser side.
So each interface in Render
has a host
in the RenderHostDirectory
called RenderViewHost
or RenderWidgetHost.
So these two things
kinda go together.
They're both sides
of the pipe.
And if you wanna write
a multi-process browser,
you use this Renderer
host layer,
which is in
chrome browser/render_host.
And just like with glue,
it shouldn't depend
on other parts of Chrome.
So it shouldn't know anything
about our browser
or the fact that we have tabs
or anything like that.
And if you wanna write
a multi-process browser,
you should be able
to grab this layer
and you're, you know,
ready to go,
writing everything else
different.
Um...so we aren't
perfect in this respect.
Sometimes it has
some bad dependencies.
But please don't add more.
So one way to think
about this is, you know,
say you're writing
a dialogue box
that has a web page in it,
but it looks kinda like
a dialogue box.
You should be able to embed
this Render host,
like a RenderViewHost,
in that
and just kind of get
a web page.
It shouldn't have all these
things like a password manager
or history or anything
like that.
So if you're wondering
where to put stuff,
if you need it
in a dialogue box
or something very simple
like that, put it there.
If it depends
on other parts of Chrome,
put it in a higher level.
So the Renderer host
has a delegate interface
which is how it talks
with the higher levels.
So that's implemented
of our tab contents layer.
And that's kind of the layer
that really integrates
with the rest
of the browser services.
So for example,
it talks to history,
it talks to, you know,
the password manager,
the navigation list
for back/forward
and all that stuff.
So tab contents kinda brings
everything together.
And, uh, above the tab contents
is the browser window.
So you shouldn't ever be
talking up directly,
so tab contents
has a tab contents delegate
that browser window implements.
And in fact,
other parts of our system
actually use tab contentses that
aren't their browser window.
So you shouldn't ever
depend on, you know,
being in a browser window.
So you talk up
through your delegate
to talk to the browser
window.
The browser window
has the tab strip,
manages tab switching,
stuff like that.
So obviously,
it's easy to talk down.
The browser window
can talk to any of its tabs.
The tab contents
can talk to the Renderer host.
These talk to glue,
and glue talks to WebKit.
And one of the things
we have on the buildbot is...
this check deps...
which is not here.
It was on the old build.
How do we get to the old build?
Does anybody know?
Oh, the old buildbot?
Okay, anyway, so there's
one step with the build.
This has check deps.
Man: Waterfall...[indistinct]
Wilson: Um...so this
check deps
tries to enforce
that you don't include
files from other parts
of the project
that you're not supposed to.
So...let's see.
Okay, so here, one of the first
steps on the main buildbot,
it updates and then it runs
through this check deps program.
So if you ever see
check deps go red,
that means that your change,
you know, for example,
included something
that it wasn't supposed to
like made a dependency
from the network library
to Chrome.
So if this ever goes red,
you need to back out your change
or fix it really fast.
Uh...not...not just make it
so that
inclusion doesn't break
the build.
'Cause that is telling you that
you're not supposed to do that.
To try to kinda
keep us honest.
And it's got a--
if you have any questions,
you can ask me about that.
It's got files in each
directory that kinda show...
oh, files in this directory
are allowed to
include base and net
but nothing else.
So there's kind of a set
of hierarchical rules
that it uses.
And...
that's my whole talk.
Anybody have any questions?
Peter: How does Darin's
rewritten Chromium port
affect all this stuff?
Wilson: I'm--I don't know.
Uh, Peter's asking
how Darin's rewritten Chromium
port in WebKit affects this.
I think it will go kind of
in-between glue and WebKit.
It's kind of--it will be using
WebKit type,
so we'll still need a glue layer
to convert types.
But it would be a more
stable API,
because right now WebKit glue
kinda talks to these
crazy WebKit classes
that change every day
and causes such problems.
But I haven't seen it.
[laughs]
Peter: Is it feasible
someday to pull out
like the Renderer host
into source/rendererhost
or something above Chrome
if it's supposed to be
kind of like a usable
embedding layer?
Wilson: Peter asked if he
could pull Renderer host
out of the Chrome browser
directory.
Maybe we haven't had
a need for that.
But it would be nice
if we were able to
and it had like
no dependencies.
But it does.
Um...yeah.
I can't think of any reason
why it shouldn't be possible.
Peter: Then you have--
you could rename WebKit glue
to be like, you know,
single process embedding layer
as a thing,
and then this would be
multi-process if anything.
Wilson: Okay, Peter has
some crazy naming ideas.
[laughter]
Peter: Thank you.
Wilson: [laughing]
Any other questions?
Okay.
[applause]